ladies and gentlemen Academy Award
winner Mira Sorvino
there's a saying that the clothes make
the man well for many of us actors it
can be said that clothes make the
character because the right costume can
magically give us that extra inspiration
to make us feel like the person that we
are playing here in Hollywood clothes or
costumes also go a long way toward
making the film making it aesthetically
the Isleta do okay good word
the aesthetically powerful and
emotionally evocative experience that it
is thank you for laughing haha tonight's
nominees for costume design masterfully
established the reality of various
periods in time they weed fantastic
visual spells that transport the
audience and they all set the tone for
the story to be told and here are the
nominees for achievement in costume
design
Colleen Atwood for her creations in the
screen version of the musical Chicago
Julie Weiss for her designs in Frieda
the biography of painter Frida Kahlo
Sandy Powell for her work in the epic
tale of Gangs of New York
and wrong her creations in interweaving
stories of the hours and Anna Shepard
for her costumes in the incredible
journey of the pianist
and the Oscar goes to Colleen Atwood for
Chicago
this is Colleen Atwoods first Academy
Award and fourth nomination she was
previously nominated in
for Sleepy Hollow 1998 for beloved and
1994
for Little Women
Oh
Chicago began for me when I walked into
a room of mirrors in watch Rob Marshall
and three choreographers danced the
entire show it was a powerful
inspiration and continued to be as a
collaboration expanded sets camera stage
lighting an amazing cast who sang and
danced dancers and my collaborators Dale
Kerr and Christine all led by Bill
Condon strip script and rods clarity and
heart thanks to you all and Tamir Max
and Marty Richards prove let it all
happen thank